The second important decision is the design of the
interconnect, or how the line cards should be connected to
one another. Now one possibility is to use a shared
bus. But the disadvantage of a bus for the interconnect
is that it can only be used by one
input-output combination. In any single time slot. What we'd like
to do is enable input output pairs that don't compete
to send traffic from input to output during the same
time slot. For example, one should be able to send to
four, two to six and three to five, all in the same
time slot. The solution to this problem is to create what's
called. A crossbar switch, or sometimes is also called a switched backplane.